Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Mitri
Sirin hallo und guten Abend den Blick
ins WM-Quartier der
Frauenfußball-Nationalmannschaft später
bei dir Christin Stichwort Aufarbeitung
guten Abend und wir blicken auf die
Themen an diesem Abend
abschleppmanöver erfolgreich der
brennende autofrachte erreicht den
Liegeplatz vor der Insel remanico
Putsch in Liga Deutschland stoppt die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und prüft den
Bundeswehreinsatz in dem Krisenstaat
immer weniger Sozialwohnungen in
Deutschland die ampelregierung kann den
negativen Trend nicht stoppen
[Musik]
die Gefahr einer möglichen
Umweltkatastrophe vor der
niederländischen Küste ist noch nicht
gebannt der seit Tagen brennende Auto
fragt da konnte zwar in einer heiklen
abschleppaktion erfolgreich zu einem
anderen Ankerplatz gezogen werden aber
das ist erstmal nur eine Zwischenlösung
mehrere Schlepper haben den Frachter von
der Insel terrelling vorbei an Ameland
bis vor sie maniko hochgezogen dort etwa
16 km von der Küste entfernt soll die
freemantel Highway jetzt erst einmal
veranker liegen bleiben bis sie in einen
Hafen verlegt werden kann mehr von
Gunnar Krüger
mittags ist er da der Auto Frachter
seine graue Silhouette gehört in dieser
verregneten Saison vorerst zum Insel
Ausblick die Bürgermeisterin kann muss
damit leben
überall nur nicht bei uns so läuft das
nicht die Wasserbehörde sagt das ist der
sicherste Ankerplatz und damit finden
wir uns ab es ist wichtig dass wir als
wattenmeerin sind solidarisch sind und
den besten Ort akzeptieren
die abschleppaktion gelang erst im
zweiten Anlauf Sonntagmorgen bete noch
Dampf und Rauch aus Südwest auf die
Schlepper Schadstoffe wären eine Gefahr
für die Besatzungen
abends als der Wind dreht und der Rauch
abnimmt der zweite Versuch 66 Kilometer
teils bei Windstärke 5 die Hülle hat
keine Risse der Rumpf ist denn Takt doch
der Frachter bleibt ein Risiko
stabil das ist für uns das Wichtigste es
kommt langsamer voran als erwartet aber
Sicherheit geht vor Tempo das Wetter ist
eben schlecht es gibt viel Wind wir
wollen sicher Vorgehen darum braucht es
Zeit
Stammgäste hält das alles nicht ab
sander-
hoffen wir dass das Schiff dort bleibt
und keine Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt
hat alle an Bord sind übrigens Fußgänger
trier-monic hoch nennt sich autofrei und
will das in jeder Hinsicht bleiben
und aufs rio ist Ulf Röller für uns Ulf
wie gefährlich ist denn die Situation
noch
also die Inselbewohner sind froh dass
der Frachter heil angekommen ist aber es
ist in weiter nervös und besorgt das
liegt einfach daran dass der Frachter
doch sehr nah an der Insel ist man kann
ihn mit dem bloßen Auge erkennen ich
will das mal zeigen da hinten jetzt ein
bisschen in den Wolken verhangen da ist
der Frachter nun und er wird von zwei
Schleppern quasi stabilisiert dann sind
noch Service Schiffe um den Frachter
herum Schiffe Spezialschiffe die Öl
falls es auslaufen sollte aufnehmen
können aber ein Restrisiko bleibt eben
weil der Vater immer noch Feuer hat und
es immer noch brennt und dann hat man
eben Angst dass es vielleicht doch Risse
in dem Mantel des Schiffes geben kann
und das wäre schlimm das ist eine
komplexe Aktion wie geht's da jetzt
weiter mit dem brennenden Frachter
also was man jetzt machen wird es gibt
da so ein technischen Ausdruck man
versucht jetzt dass der Frachter quasi
kontrolliert ausbrennt man wird auch
kontrolliert löschen nicht zu viel
Wasser damit der Frachter nicht voll
läuft und kippt und wenn einem das
gelungen ist das Feuer mehr der weniger
zu bekämpfen und weg zu bekommen dann
gehen inspektionsteams auf den Frachter
drauf und gucken an wie groß der Schaden
ist und aufgrund dieser Analyse wird
dann quasi entschieden was mit dem
Frachter passiert und wo er zu welchem
endhafen kommt aber wie gesagt dass es
noch nicht entschieden danke für die
aktuellen Informationen ultra ja über
die Brandursache wird ja noch spekuliert
als eine wahrscheinliche Möglichkeit
gilt dass sich eines der knapp 500
Elektroautos an Bord entzündet hat und
das befeuert auch die Diskussion ob von
E-Autos und deren Batterien größere
Gefahren ausgehen in diesem Zusammenhang
forderte der Bund Auto Transporter auf
dem Meer künftig als
gefahrenguttransporte zu deklarieren
Martin
wenn ein Auto erstmal brennt muss der
Brand mit Wasser bekämpft werden Wasser
gegen die Flammen aber auch zur
Abkühlung was vor allem für die
Batterien oder Akkus von Elektroautos
nötig ist es ist heute weniger die
E-Mobilität ein Thema die E-Autos
brennen wie die Benziner und Dieselautos
sondern es ist mehr das Thema dass die
Autos intensiver Brillen durch die
höheren Kunststoffanteile und durch den
Kunststoff brennen die Autos heftiger
und sie brennen von den schneller von
Auto zur Auto noch ist die Brandursache
auf dem Frachter im Watten mehr unklar
potentielle elektroautokäufer lassen
sich offenbar nicht verunsichern
natürlich muss man darauf achten dass
sowas nie wieder passiert und das war
gewisse sicherheitsregularien auch
einhält und gewisse Erfahrungen auch in
dieser Nische betrachtet und jetzt nicht
alles auf E-Mobilität stürzt sondern
einfach auch die Sicherheit für die
Menschen für die Umwelt im Kopf
Behältnis Unglück einfach und ich habe
sehr viele andere brennende Fahrzeuge
auch schon auf den Straßen gesehen und
es waren keine eV Fahrzeuge von dem her
glaube ich hält sich dass die Waage
bestätigt der Gesamtverband der
Versicherer GDV Elektrofahrzeuge brennen
nicht häufiger als andere bleibt die
Brandbekämpfung die kann nicht
erfolgreich sein wo die Feuerwehr nicht
rankommen kann die Lösung wäre mehr
Platz doch der kostet auch mehr Geld
sollten uns wirklich jetzt diesen auch
Vorfall zum Anlass nehmen egal was
passiert ist und was schuld ist und zu
überlegen ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist
dass wir Produkte die wir eigentlich vor
Ort herstellen sollten weite Wege übers
Meer schicken durch große
Temperaturdifferenzen kalt und warm um
die dann nachher gehen zu transportieren
oder ob wir das nicht lieber vor Ort
machen sollten technisch machbar wäre
das in Deutschland aber auch das ist
letztlich nicht nur eine Frage der
Sicherheit sondern auch das Geld ist
mit großer Sorge schauen viele gerade
auf den afrikanischen Kontinent immer
mehr Länder dort werden von Militärs
beherrscht inzwischen haben sie in Mali
in Burkina Faso im Chat und im Sudan das
Sagen und seit letzter Woche auch in
Niger
generaliani hat sich dort an die Macht
geputzt die Lage auf den Straßen die ist
angespannt Nachbarstaaten die EU und
auch Deutschland wollen den staatsreich
nicht hinnehmen und für alle hängt jetzt
viel von der Entwicklung in den nächsten
Tagen ab Jan Fritzsche dazu
es sind diese Bilder vom Wochenende die
die Sorgen vor einer Eskalation des
Konflikts in Niger wachsen lassen in der
Hauptstadt nyamei demonstrieren tausende
für die Putschisten sie greifen die
Botschafter ehemaligen Kolonialmacht
Frankreich an schwenken stattdessen
russische Flaggen und skandieren Putin
die westafrikanischen Staaten erhöhen
gestern bei einer Krisensitzung den
Druck auf die Putschisten der gewählte
Präsident bei Zoom müsse freigelassen
und wieder eingesetzt werden
sollten unsere Forderungen nicht binnen
einer Woche erfüllt werden werden wir
alles Nötige tun um die
Verfassungsordnung in Niger
wiederherzustellen das kann auch die
Anwendung von Gewalt einschließen
die EU und die USA unterstützen das
Vorgehen der Westafrikaner vor allem für
Frankreich steht viel auf dem Spiel das
Land hat rund 2000 Soldaten in Niger und
ist für seine Atomkraftwerke auf
nigerisches Uran angewiesen auch
Deutschland prüft jetzt die Konsequenzen
für seine Soldaten in Niger und den
geplanten Abzug aus Mali
dort zu verantworten haben haben erklärt
dass sie sich an alle
internationalen Absprachen und
Vereinbarungen halten wollen das wird
jetzt zu prüfen sein ich sagte ja schon
dass wir dabei sind auch alternativ
alternative Wege zu suchen wie wir
unsere unser Kontingent aus Malia
rausbekommen einer der Putschisten
meldet sich heute per Video angeblich
plane Frankreich zusammen mit der
abgesetzten Regierung eine
Befreiungsaktion des bisherigen
Präsidenten Belege dafür gibt es nicht
die Befürchtung des Westens ist Niger
könnte sich wie schon seine
Nachbarländer Russland zuwenden das
sucht seit dem Ukraine Krieg neue
Partner und ist mit der söl Zielgruppe
Wagner zum Beispiel in Mali aktiv doch
Experten relativieren Großteil ist sehr
sehr gut in mobilisieren von Leuten was
dann immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck
vortäuscht dass da sehr groß
Unterstützung für Russland existiert
ob die Militärmacht habe in Niger sich
wirklich vom Westen abwenden und an
Russland binden wollen ist noch unklar
klar ist der internationale Druck auf
die Putschisten wächst
jetzt zur Ukraine da meldet die
Regierung weiter geländegewinner
vergangene Woche sein fast 15
Quadratkilometer von Russland zurück
erobert worden gleichzeitig greift
Russland weiterstädte im Süden und Osten
der Ukraine an in der Heimatstadt von
Präsident selensky priviri schlugen zwei
russische Raketen in einen neuen
stöckiges Wohnhaus und ein Gebäude der
Universität ein mindestens sechs
Menschen sein dabei getötet worden mehr
als 75 verletzt auch in Person starben
vier Menschen durch russischen
Artillerie Beschuss
der Verfassungsschutz führt die AFD als
rechtsextremen Verdachtsfall und fühlt
sich nach der europawahlversammlung der
Partei bestätigt diverse afd-kandidaten
hätten dort rechtsextremistische
Verschwörungstheorien geäußert so
Behördenchef Haldenwang Vertreter des
ehemaligen gemäßigteren Lagers würden so
gut wie keine Rolle mehr spielen und
verfassungsfeindliche Strömungen
zunehmen
die Ampelkoalition hatte sich ja den Bau
von 100.000 Sozialwohnungen pro Jahr als
zielgesetz aber davon ist man noch
ziemlich weit entfernt im vergangenen
Jahr wurden nur
22.545 Wohnungen für Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen gebaut gleichzeitig
fehlen aber
36.500 weg weil die Sozialbindung
auslief Ende des Jahres gab es damit
bundesweit nur noch rund eine Million
Sozialwohnungen im Rahmen unserer Reihe
ZDF in zeigt Beatrice Steinecke in
Rostock die Schwierigkeiten bezahlbaren
Wohnraum zu schaffen
5.500 Wohnungen fehlen in der Hansestadt
Rostock dies könnte ein neuer Standort
sein Platz für bis zu 1.200 Wohnungen
plus Gewerbegebiet gegen die Baupläne
hat sich allerdings eine
Bürgerinitiative gegründet
also ich bin Sozialarbeiterin ich würde
sofort nichts sagen wenn wir hier
sozialen Wohnungsbau machen würden aber
ich glaube dass die Erschließung der
Fläche so teuer ist dass hier doch
wieder nur eine bestimmte Menschengruppe
wohnen könnte das Gelände gehört fast
ausschließlich der Stadt sie will selbst
erschließen die Vergabe der Grundstücke
an konkrete Vorgaben knüpfen am Ende
wollen wir natürlich bezahlbaren
Wohnraum anbieten das ist ein ganz
schwieriges Unterfangen die Baukosten
sind in den letzten Monaten und Jahren
extrem in die Höhe gegangen das ist eine
riesige Herausforderung bis zu 30% der
jährlich neu gebauten Wohnungen in
Rostock sollen sozial gefördert werden
bei den bestehenden läuft die Förderung
nach einer bestimmten Zeit aus daher
sinkt die Zahl der Sozialwohnungen in
Deutschland stetig in den letzten zehn
Jahren um rund ein Drittel die kommunale
Wohnungsgesellschaft baut in Rostock
Lichtenhagen 42 neue Sozialwohnungen der
Bauherr kritisiert die Richtlinien des
Landes das aktuelle Förderprogramm ist
so gestrickt und so definiert
dass es mit den aktuellen Preisen nicht
harmonisiert das heißt wenn ich eine
geförderte Wohnung baue nach diesem
Programm bleibe ich am Ende auf Kosten
sitzen Experten sind sich einig ohne
deutlich mehr Förderung von Land und
Bund etwa mit einem Sondervermögen oder
einem höheren Wohngeld lässt sich
bezahlbares Wohnen kaum realisieren
wegen der geplatzten Pkw-Maut muss der
Bund ja 243 Millionen Euro Schadenersatz
an die vorgesehenen Betreiber zahlen und
Verkehrsminister Wissing der lässt jetzt
prüfen ob sein CSU Amtsvorgänger
scheuert dafür in Regress genommen
werden kann das sei eine juristische und
keine politische Frage so wissen die CSU
nennt wissingspläne ein durchsichtiges
Wahlkampfmanöver ja können Politiker für
ihre Entscheidungen haftbar gemacht
werden damit beschäftigt sich heute auch
heute live um 19:30 Uhr geht's los auf
ZDF heute und auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen
mögliche Regressforderung kommen auch
auf klimaaktivisten der letzten
Generation zu nach Blockaden an mehreren
Flughäfen will der Lufthansa-Konzern
jetzt Schadensersatz geltend machen es
geht dabei um Flugausfälle in Düsseldorf
und Hamburg am 13 juli und um eine
Blockade am Berliner Hauptstadtflughafen
im November
2022 so eine Konzernsprecherin
die krankenhausreform ist ein wichtiges
Projekt der Bundesregierung klar ist
aber auch nicht alle Kliniken in
Deutschland werden überleben die
Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft rechnet
nach einer Umfrage damit das 15 Prozent
innerhalb der kommenden 10 Jahren
schließen müssen 69% der Kliniken sehen
sich mittelfristig in ihrer Existenz
gefährdet was das konkret bedeutet zeigt
Susanne Freitag an einem Beispiel aus
dem Saarland
auf der Intensivstation des Klinikums in
Merzig Standardbetrieb so scheint es
zumindest aber das Krankenhaus hat
Insolvenz angemeldet erst kam kowitt
dann die Inflation die Schulden zu hoch
Reißleine im Moment gibt es einen
Schutzschirm der Betrieb läuft erst
einmal weiter vorübergehend das ist das
erstmal wichtig dass das Krankenhaus
hier bleibt weil hier die Region ganz
einfach ein Krankenhaus Brei braucht um
halt hier die Menschen zu versorgen was
ist dazu notwendig notwendig ist
natürlich dazu dass wir
zukunftsrechtliche sichere
planungszahlen haben wir brauchen also
ganz einfach verlässliche Fakten aber
zahlen und konkrete Konzepte fehlen noch
die krankenhausreform ist angekündigt
aber viele Krankenhäuser werden
schließen müssen bevor sie überhaupt in
Kraft tritt ob Merzig erhalten bleibt
telebialek wurde hier zweimal am Knie
einmal an der Hüfte behandelt Merzig ist
das Einzige akut-krankenhaus in seiner
Nähe
wenn es sonst nichts gibt es ja für die
Angehörigen oder die die her müssen ist
es ja kacke wenn die weit weiter weg
müssen oder so deswegen ich wäre schon
dafür dass man am Leben erhält die
Reform sieht vor dass es künftig
vorhaltepauschalen statt Fall
Abrechnungen gibt das Personal ist
skeptisch
die Ärzte müssen trotzdem 24 Stunden 7
Tage die Woche vorgehalten werden
entsprechender Standard
Pflegepersonal genau dasselbe
Dienstpläne sind geschrieben ob jetzt
wenig Patienten da sind und dann viele
erst einmal fordern die Krankenhäuser
jetzt einen sofortigen
Inflationsausgleich sonst ist die Welle
der klinikschließungen kaum aufzuhalten
Temperaturen weit über 40 Grad
Griechenland Ärzte echte heißt es
natürlich mehr als zwei Wochen unter
enormer Hitze hinzu kamen zahlreiche
Waldbrände und auch wenn sich die Lage
inzwischen leicht entspannt hat im
gesamten Land sind tausende Hektar Wald
und landwirtschaftlich genutzte Flächen
von den Flammen zerstört worden und es
bleibt weiterhin im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes brandgefährlich Barbara Look
verbrannte Erde alles erstarrt rund um
Athen gibt es kaum noch grüne Flächen
das Feuer hat Wälder Felder Fabriken
mitgerissen und die die hier leben sind
voller Sorge und so wütend
wenn es im ganzen Land brennt was soll
man zuerst löschen es fehlt ein
Organisation und guten Flugzeugen
der Staat muss viel mehr für die Umwelt
tun der Mittelmeerraum wird im Sommer
immer mehr zum Waldbrand Hotspot in
Griechenland kämpfen sie seit Wochen
gegen die Flammen Klimawandel
Erderwärmung als Brandbeschleuniger der
Süden der immer heißer und trockener
wird in Europa sind bereits im letzten
Jahr 1,6 Millionen Hektar verbrannt
wir brauchen ein neues Waldmanagement
müssen feuerresistentere Bäume pflanzen
uns anpassen und die vielen Touristen
die sich hier im Sommer tummeln müssen
sich eher auf das ganze Jahr verteilen
auch die Landflucht begünstigt hier das
Feuer denn immer mehr Menschen ziehen in
die Städte Felder verwildern und wuchern
zu gefährlichem Brennmaterial im Dorf
Stefani sitzt Anastasios mit den anderen
vor dem geschlossenen Café und erzählt
dass hier kaum noch jemand ist
Galerie alles hat sich verändert so
anders wie Tag und Nacht
weiter südlich Fluten Touristen gerade
Athen alles rappelvoll doch die Brände
machen viele auch nachdenklich also ich
glaube man muss insgesamt das ganze
Reiseverhalten irgendwie ändern also wir
sind zum Beispiel mit dem Schiff und mit
dem Zug angereist ich finde sehr
erschreckend also ich finde das zeigt
einfach wie stark der Klimawandel schon
fortgeschritten ist
währenddessen kämpfen sie in vielen
Teilen Griechenlands immer noch gegen
das wiederaufflammende Feuer
ja und in Australien da versuchen die
deutschen Fußballerinnen die gestrige
Pleite zu verarbeiten Christian
Niederlage die Zeit drängt der Druck ist
natürlich groß ein Sieg ist Pflicht
Donnerstagmittag gegen Südkorea live im
ZDF um in Brisbane das eigene Hand die
Ko-Runde bei der WM zu sichern bedeutet
Konzentration auf das Wesentliche und
möglichst nicht aus der Ruhe bringen
lassen
eine kalte Dusche gab es für
Bundestrainerin Martina Forst
Tecklenburg gleich schon wieder heute
morgen gestern wurde ihre Mannschaft in
der Nachspielzeit kalt erwischt beim
Gegentor dass die eins zu zwei
Niederlage besiegelte und eine kritische
aber nicht zu kritische Nacharbeitung
erforderte jetzt wirklich nur drauf zu
hauen und alles wieder schlecht zu reden
nur wenn man verloren hat bin ich auch
kein Freund von heute waren die
Aussichten schon wieder sonniger
selbstbewusst bleiben ist jetzt wichtig
sicher ein Pluspunkt das im
entscheidenden Gruppenspiel gegen
Südkorea Abwehrchefin Marina Hegering
wieder einsatzbereit wäre hilfreich
wären aber auch mehr zwingende
Torchancen damit Deutschland nach der
Vorrunde nicht im Regen steht
tja sechs Nationen stehen bereits im
Achtelfinale nach Norwegen und der
Schweiz auch Japan und Spanien die
Japanerinnen makellos gruppenärzte 4:0
gegen die Spanierinnen die als zweite
weiter sind alle Spiele und Tore auf ZDF
heute.de außerdem reichen Nigeria einen
0:0 gegen Irland zum Turnier verbleibt
überraschend raus die Olympiasiegerinnen
aus Kanada die zum Vorrunden Abschluss
klar den Australien Unterlagen
sie ist die matchwinnerin Haley resso
bei diesem traumsieg der Gastgeber
Australien weiter tanzen lässt und die
Party geht früh los schon in der neunten
Minute bringt sie die 30.000 Fans im
Stadion zum Kochen mit viel Zeit trifft
du es so zum 1:0 und dann ist es in der
39 Minute ihrer blitzreaktion zu
verdanken dass der Ball wieder im Tor
landet 2:0 schon in der 58 Minute wird
dann langsam klar Australien macht es
klar Mary Fowler mit dem Glück im
Abschluss zum drei zu null
in der Nachspielzeit setzt Def catley
vom Elfmeter Punkt
Australien gewinnt so 4:0 und besiegelt
das Bittere WM aus für Olympiasieger
Kanada
und ich habe noch schwimmen zum Auftakt
der parallelmeisterschaften in
Manchester gab es gleich die erste
Medaille für das deutsche Team Maurice
Wette kam gewonnen über 100 Meter Brust
Silber der 17-Jährige aus Leverkusen mit
einer Fehlbildung am Arm musste sich nur
dem Italieners der Fano remondy
geschlagen geben ja wie schön erste
Medaille so kann es weitergehen danke
Christian ja beim Wetter allerdings
nicht aber was willst du machen
regnerisch und er kühl die Aussichten
für die ersten August Tage Katja
Ronacher gleich mit mehr um 21:45 Uhr
begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers zum heute
journal und morgen an dieser Stelle Jana
pareises schönen Abend danke auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine sehr
wechselhafte wetterwoche schon in den
vergangenen 24 Stunden sind viele
Regenwolken besonders über den Norden
und die Mitte Deutschlands hinweggezogen
und jetzt entwickelt sich gerade ein
neuer Regen der hier vom Ärmelkanal von
Frankreich und den Benelux-Staaten zu
uns reinzieht der breitet sich im Laufe
der Nacht vor allen Dingen über den
Westen und den Süden Deutschlands aus
kleinere Bäche und Flüsse können dadurch
aus über die Ufer treten eine
überregionale Hochwasserlage brauchen
wir aber derzeit nicht zu befürchten
weniger kräftig ist der Regen hier im
Nordosten bei Südwest wird die
Temperaturen sinken auf 17 bis 13 Grad
und der Regen der Nacht sieht morgen
über Tag dann weiter ostwärts dann
lockern die Wolken mal kurz auf und dann
entwickeln sich kräftige Schauer und
Gewitter und auch morgen kommt der Wind
sehr bösig aus westlichen bis
südwestlichen Richtung im Dauergrau am
alten Rand steigen die Temperaturen
morgen bis 17 Grad 23 Grad werden es am
Mittel und am Oberrhein und auch in den
nächsten Tagen geht es sehr wechselhaft
weiter sehr windig zum Teil besonders am
Mittwoch hier im Südwesten und das bei
Temperaturen von 17 bis 25 Grad guten
Abend